THE WEST WING AT ENTRANCE, THE
PRESIDENT LEAVING EARLIER TO
HOST A CAMPAIGN-STYLE RALLY IN
ABOUT AN HOUR AND A HALF IN
NASHVILLE.
THE TENNESSEE U.S. SENATE RACE
FIGURES TO BE CRUCIAL AND BOTH
PARTIES AT FIRST ARE TRYING TO
CONTROL THE U.S. SENATE AFTER
THIS YEAR.
CORRESPONDENT STEVE HARRIGAN IS
IN NASHVILLE TONIGHT.
>> Reporter: AT THE MOST
EXPENSIVE RACE IN TENNESSEE
HISTORY COULD CONTROL THE U.S.
SENATE.
>> IT WILL BE HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE, LOTS OF MONEY FROM
THE OUTSIDE POURED INTO THIS
RACE.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT MIGHT BE THE
PIVOT THAT TURNS ON WHETHER THE
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS ON.
>> Reporter: MARTHA BLACKBURN
CARRIES A PISTOL IN HER PURSE
AND PROCLAIMS SUPPORT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP OFTEN.
>> I STAND WHEN HE WALKS INTO
THE ONE.
AND YES, I STAND WHEN I HEAR OF
"THE STAR-SPANGLED BANNER."
>> Reporter: THE DEMOCRAT,
FORMER GOVERNOR PHIL BROADUS AND
CALLS HIMSELF A PROBLEM SOLVER
AND IT REALLY MEANT MENTIONS THE
PRESIDENT AT ALL.
>> THE LESS HE HAS TO TAKE ON
NATIONAL POLITICS, THE BETTER
FOR HIM.
THE MORE HE CAN KEEP IT LOCAL
AND STATEWIDE ISSUES I THINK
THAT PORTENDS BETTER FOR HIM
COME NOVEMBER.
>> Reporter: IT IS A BALANCING
ACT FOR A DEMOCRAT AND IT IN THE
STATE TRUMP WON BY MORE THAN 20
POINTS.
>> I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
ROUGH AROUND THE EDGES BUT HE’S
DOING OKAY.
>> Reporter: BLACKBURN KNOWS
SHE’S IN FOR A FIGHT.
>> I THINK IT’S CLOSE BECAUSE MY
OPPONENT DID SERVE AS GOVERNOR
FOR TWO TERMS AND HE HAS RUN
STATEWIDE THREE TIMES, THIS
WOULD BE HIS FOURTH, STATEWIDE
RACE.
AND PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH HIS
NAME.
>> Reporter: AND WHAT IS
LIKELY TO BE A TIGHT RACE, IS
EXPECTED TO DO WELL IN THE
CITIES.
THEY WILL BOTH BATTLE FOR THE
RURAL VOTE.
>> AND THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
BE IN THERE TO DO SOMETHING TO
HELP MAKE HIS AGENDA TO GET
AMERICA BACK ON THE ROAD AGAIN.
>> Reporter: PRESIDENT TRUMP
WON SOME COUNTIES IN TENNESSEE
WITH ALMOST 90% OF THE VOTE.
THE QUESTION NOW FOR THE SENATE